hey guys how's it going so today I
tweeted about my Apple watch it might
have went through the washing machine I
didn't know I put my sister was like hey
I just took your clothes washer so that
she could do her laundry and she said
that the Apple watch fell out so after I
tweeted this everyone's like oh my gosh
whatever you do don't throw it on the
charger and make sure you put it in rice
and do all of this stuff well when I
tweeted that it was probably like two or
three hours after the fact that it
already had happened and the first thing
that I did was throw it onto the charger
and I left the house there's the Apple
watch it just got back we're gonna do a
little test and see if it happens to
work cross your fingers
I'm gonna put you guys on top of this
coffee I'm gonna remove the watch from
cradle there's definitely some scratches
if you guys can tell like right here
right there and this is the steel
edition so it's a little bit stronger
than the Sport Edition so I came to
imagine if this was the sport it
probably would have been destroyed so
let's fire this thing up so I can start
playing some battlefront
see if it works ready okay it says the
battery is dead that's not good because
it's been charging for a while no why
you got to do this why was I so stupid
I don't know how got in there being
shipped 6 o'clock is it even 6 o'clock
ok it's actually 6 o'clock so that's
that's a good thing hmm I think you're
you might be dead
maybe I'm taking to the Apple store
really kay I might have put this in the
washer free Apple it says it's just I
wanted to double-check to force reset
you hold this in for 10 seconds so
so it's not doing anything it's not
charging well guys that's the Apple
watch dilemma do not put your Apple
watch in the washer I'll keep you guys
posted maybe just maybe it'll start back
up let's hope for the best little guy
I'll see you soon
on the other side say hello to it bye Oh
oh that's pretty secure yeah I think
we're okay yeah we're good what's this
this drove a bag of drugs